this video is sponsored by blinkist
understand key ideas from books in just
15 minutes use the link in the
description and you receive one free
week and 25% off and annual premium
membership you're sitting in a small
Alleyway between your apartment building
and the building next door getting some
fresh air and enjoying some coffee a
single snowflake falls on the ground
next to you you don't notice not long
after another snowflake falls in the
same relative spot again you don't
notice over the following couple of
hours more snow flakes fall in the same
concentrated area directed by a draft
and a small Whirlwind created by the
space between the two buildings at some
point you notice and you determine that
you are now sitting next to a heap of
snow you were there observing the same
area the whole time but only now do you
determine that next to you is a heap of
snow but then when did the snowflakes
turn into a heap did one additional
snowflake cause this change which number
snowflake did if one did
can a single snowflake possibly be the
difference between a non-heap of snow
and a Heap what if now after the snow is
stopped assuming you could you take an
individual snowflake off of the Heap
would it still be a Heap what if you
took another snowflake off and another
what if you kept taking snowflakes off
would there be a point along the way at
which the Heap would no longer be a heap
at some point ultimately you'd be left
with only one snowflake certainly not a
heap but if once snowflake is not a heap
then is two is three now we're back
where we
started is there really such thing as a
heap at
all this is a version of what is known
as cides Paradox in plain terms the
Paradox is that if a single flake of
snow or grain of sand or anything
similar is not a heap then adding one
flake to it does not create a heap It
seems impossible that one flake could
make the difference between a non-heap
and a heap so therefore two flakes are
also not a heap however using this Logic
No matter how many flakes of snow are
continually added one by one there will
never be a heap of snow but of course we
know there can be heaps of snow hence
the
Paradox this Paradox points out a
problem with how we Define classify and
identify things how language maps onto
reality and how we manipulate reality
with
language arguably the term Heap refers
to a concept a quality of something in
this case the quality of a group of
things the problem and Paradox however
is caused by the vagueness of the term
Heap doesn't have clear boundaries for
what it is or isn't when we see a heap
we know that's a heap but the vagueness
of what a heap actually is in reality
becomes clear when one is taken apart
when we break a heap down the concept of
a heap breaks down itself although this
is most easily and clearly exemplified
in something like like a keep a similar
problem can arise when referring to
almost
anything the problem of
universals in the case of heaps of snow
philosophically the term Heap here is
considered a universal the specific Heap
next to you is what is referred to as a
particular or the specific instance in
which the universal is exemplified more
broadly universals are properties that
are fully instantiated or exemplified by
different objects and phenomena in the
world this includes things like
greenness squareness tallness
beautifulness and so on these entities
are abstract so they don't exist in time
and space and thus they can exist in
multiple places at the same time
conversely particulars are concrete
which do exist in time and space and
thus can only exist in one place at any
given time for example imagine there are
two heaps of snow now one next to you
and one across the street there are both
heaps of snow and so in this sense they
are both the same thing and this is
where universals come in but of course
they are also completely different
things they both are made of entirely
different snow formed into different
shapes exist in different places and so
forth each Heap here is its own
particular so both are the same thing
heaps of snow and yet both are different
things as another perhaps less extreme
and clearer example consider the chair
you are sitting on while observing the
snow let's say the chair is green in
this case the chair under you is the
particular in which the universals of
things like greenness and chairess are
represented now let's also say you have
three more of the same chair each of
these other chairs are the exact same
color shape size and of the same
manufacturer but yet they are of course
all different particular chairs they
each occupy different space at different
times they are each made of entirely
unique collections of matter and so
forth their existence is wholly separate
and unique from each other and yet
simultaneously they're all the same
chair and that's most likely how you or
anyone would refer to them when speaking
generally but what actually makes
something the same as other things if
each individual instance of the thing is
a completely different thing a separate
physical object or phenomenon or put
differently how can different things
have identical properties if they are
different
things the problem in philosophy known
as the problem of universals stems from
this obscurity and how we identify what
makes things the same the convoluted
nature of sameness and
separateness the most intuitive and
obvious way to deal with this problem is
to just describe the qualities that
things have in common and if they have
enough in common then referring to them
with the same Universal is Justified but
now we're back at the problem of the
Heap how many properties in common make
things the same thing how many
metaphorical grains of sand or flakes of
snow suddenly permit one individual
thing into a group of the same thing
taking it even further to say that
objects have something in common means
that there must be this other thing in
reality that they have in common
greenness Heap chairess bigness and so
on using the example of the chairs if
the green color small size chair shape
and manufacturer make the chairs the
same then the greenness smallness
chairess and manufactur must be a
present thing that exists in each chair
one cannot say that green makes one
thing the same as something else if
green isn't a real Present part of
reality but what really is chairess and
greenness are they actually real parts
of reality this is the problem of
universals do these abstract properties
exist beyond the objects they are
instantiated by and if so in what way
the philosophical camp known as realists
believes that universals like greenness
chairess heatness and so on actually do
exist in reality and are independent of
the mind this line of thinking follows
from the theory of forms developed by
the classic Greek philosopher Plato in
which Plato drew a distinction between
two Realms of reality physical objects
that we can perceive with our senses and
the realm of ideas which we can only
grasp through our intellect and reason
since for Plato all objects in the
physical world change over time like for
example a rock will erode and become
sand but ideas like the idea of a Rock
are ultimate and enduring then the realm
of ideas is more real than the realm of
objects if particulars are to have
meaning there must be universals Plato
says alternatively the philosophical
camp known as nominalists believe that
universals are only terms used to
describe things but don't exist in
reality they are merely words and
labels lastly somewhat in the middle of
the two conceptualists believe that
universals exist in our perception but
not in in the outside world in other
words they only exist within the
mechanisms of our mind other
philosophers typically adjacent to
nominalists argue that there is never
anything truly shared between two or
more objects two green chairs both
possess two unique qualities of
greenness and chairess entirely specific
to each we simply lump all the green
chairs together only as a result of
their resemblance to
us here we arrive at another
philosophical problem the Criterion of
identity or principle of
individuation the Criterion of identity
relates to the following problem how do
we determine what makes an individual
thing distinct from other things what is
the standard by which we are to judge
the identity of something as being
unique and itself what makes you a
person and not a heap of particles what
makes you you and not someone else or
someone different from yourself across
time perhaps the best way to explore
this problem is through the classic
thought experiment the ship of
Theus after voyaging to cre and slaying
an evil Minotaur one of the most
distructive and terrifying Monsters of
the Greek mythical world the Divine
founder and hero of Athens Theus sailed
home and commemoration of this
unbelievable feat the Athenians would
decide to keep thesis's ship in the
harbor and meticulously maintain it
while each year reenacting thesis's
Voyage as years and years would go by
every time a part of the ship became
worn damaged or defective it would be
replaced with an identical piece made of
the exact same material gradually after
hundreds and hundreds of years the ship
in the harbor will become comprised of
entirely new parts with no original
parts
remaining the question we are left with
here is as follows is the ship in the
harbor still the ship of
Theus after the first part of the ship
is replaced most people would likely
still consider it the ship of Theus but
if this is true Sur the second part
being replaced the third part and quite
a few more parts to come would still not
affect the ship of Theus being the ship
of Theus but by the end how can a ship
that does not have a single part in
common be the same ship and if it isn't
the ship of Theus at this point when did
it stop being the ship of Theus if it is
a different ship once one thing changes
weren't some things always changing to
some degree before any parts were
replaced mild erosions scuffs things
being put on and taken off and so on if
it's only the ship of Theus if Theus
uses it been on it or perhaps owns it
what if he had been on parts of the new
one and is considered the owner and what
if someone then took all of the old
parts that were removed and then put
them back together in the form of
another ship now there are two ships
that he's been on and owned in different
capacities which would be the true ship
of Theus if there can only be one which
one is more his or perhaps neither the
ship of
thesias
ultimately this Paradox demonstrates the
vagueness and uncertainty around the
Persistence of identity in a world of
change and plurality we cannot clearly
and concretely Define what something is
over time moreover we cannot clearly
tell that something is the same thing as
itself over time we can only call it the
same thing and create or lean into the
illusions of the mind that help us
organize and form a linear tracking of
things together the ship of Theus the
iion of identity the problem of
universals and sores Paradox demonstrate
how terms and Concepts have a much
looser relationship with reality than we
like to think ultimately we use terms
and ideas to communicate and interface
with the world of objects and other
people but even in just these fairly
simple cases of examination the methods
of language conceptualization and
categorization reach the limits of their
abilities it is an incredible wonder and
achievement that given the uncertainty
and obscurity of all of this everything
in the world the human mind can still so
easily and intuitively form such
impressive Feats of organization and
perceptual calibration of understanding
the world in a coherent and functional
way in a way that can allow societies
and cities to be built love to be
expressed confusion to be articulated
shared and overcome we form our systems
our identities our preferences our
knowledge real or pseudo out from this
ability and perhaps at bottom that's all
that really matters but perhaps also at
times it can be useful to dive head
first into the Heap of obscurity and
examine things just a little bit closer
to remember that everything we think we
know and think we are is far more
malleable vague and uncertain and in
doing so we can perhaps counteract the
fair share of problems that come with
rigid attachment to ideas and thinking
in terms of binary opposition we can
perhaps counteract Prejudice bias narrow
mindedness and so on in truth we have
all come to hold our Illusions and
Frameworks of perception near and dear
but take one flake away one wooden plank
away one part of your brain away and
what are you left
with this video was sponsored by
blinkist consider one more Paradox
you've just discovered the app blinkist
where you can understand the most
important ideas from over 6,600
non-fiction books through 15-minute
explainers after getting the app first
you listen to the stuff of thought by
Stephen Pinker where you learn about
what language teaches us about human
nature how it affects human behavior and
often gets us into trouble it's so
thought-provoking convenient and
enjoyable you immediately continue on to
a second book the doubt a jing by Lau
where you learn about the fluidity of
everything and how to understand what
you cannot describe you continue using
blinkist every day listening to at least
several expl planners every week at the
end of each week your knowledge
significantly increases and you vastly
improve your understanding of yourself
the world your career and so on of
course however at the end of each week
you feel like the same person by the end
of the year however after continuing
this habit and absorbing countless
life-changing ideas on blankest you feel
like a completely different person
compared to when you started at what
point then did you become a different
person if you felt the same after each
individual week can it be pinpointed if
not the first week was it the second the
third was it at any point of course this
is an example of the ship of thesias and
how this problem can so easily apply to
many things what isn't paradoxical
however is that blinkist makes it easy
for just about anyone to become a new
improved version of themselves and now
with blinket spaces you can easily share
books with those close to you and help
friends and family discover new versions
of themselves as well even without
having blink as premium click the link
in the description and you'll receive a
free 7-Day trial and 25% off and annual
premium blanket subscription and of
course thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next
video